we had sexuality this is gonna be a
make-believe
okay the second coming of Nick sup guys
and a long-awaited question you know I'm
an ordained minister how are you this is
your The Bachelor greatest seasons ever
season 1 episode to recap grab your
glasses it's time for roses and Rose Bay
hi everybody it's me Lauren Zima and I'm
coming to you guys from my apartment yes
yes yes we are still being corn chic but
I have moved to my apartment to film
roses and Rosie's giving us the
beautiful space giving us a different
vibe giving us very blank walls III will
admit I have moved in here just before
the pandemic hits so I haven't had a ton
of moments to decorate it we've added
some pops of red you know some flowers
and most importantly we have wine I have
a cool new wine glass very exciting I do
have some ice in it because well I
forgot to put this in the refrigerator
but whatever we got to keep on keepin on
and doing our best everybody okay so
this is the bachelor goat the greatest
of all time The Bachelor the greatest
seasons ever the greatest seasons ever
and you know what else is great for and
it right
[Music]
skill I have I don't know if I should be
proud of it
okay I'm also everybody if I'm moving
very strangely I I slept on my neck real
weird and this is all I got that's all I
got
camera one camera two camera one camera
two camera one camera two camera one
camera two let's get to it
hi babes I'm coming to you guys with the
vlog from my car I'm a mess right now I
need coffee but I just wanted to just in
the moment react to Matt James being The
Bachelor the announcement is such a
moment of happiness
I want to soak that in for many reasons
one because Matt himself I think is
awesome you guys Matt for bachelor I
actually interviewed him before
Claire season was about to start
production because he was gonna be one
of the contestants and I was so
impressed with him in that interview it
was his first interview and a lot of
people get nervous and I understand that
but he was dynamic and he had awesome
answers so I actually said in that
moment Matt for bachelor I will pose
that and also because that's going to be
the first black bachelor and this is
long overdue and I think and I hope that
this will mean evolution for the
franchise I just stabbed happy about
this and I think it's a good step and
that's what we've got to take we've got
to take steps forward growth and change
and move forward positively so that's
what I'm feeling in this moment and
again I think Matt's gonna be awesome
let me know what you guys think of Matt
let me know in the comments below I
really need coffee I love you guys so
much
bye e but also see in a minute rows and
rows a yeah welcome
this is different on this season of The
Bachelorette Kaitlyn Bristowe season you
might not remember but in the beginning
we had a lot of bachelorettes yes this
was the one season ever where we've
started with not one but two leads so
right off the bat
don't drink for every lead I'm ready so
we had Kaitlyn Bristowe and Britt
Nielson I think was her last name I
guess technically neither of them had
been given the title of Bachelorette yet
the premise was that on night one
the men would all vote of course with
roses and choose which woman would be
the Bachelorette and you know Kaitlyn
has said she didn't love that and I
don't blame her this is good Lauren stop
turning your neck so quickly take it
slow okay
but I do raise my glass to whoever took
the time to literally make a rose shaped
cut out in those like rose voting boxes
the details so you know it was woman
versus woman and it was awkward they're
both arriving at the mansion and
Kaitlyn's face is saying it all and then
the men are arriving at the mansion and
Ben Higgins his face is saying at all
really it's awkward well this is awkward
but long story short because this show
is the CliffsNotes of these seasons and
you know we actually know the outcome
anyway so spoiler alert but not really
Britt is not the Bachelorette and Chris
Harrison had to give her that newest
didn't he unfortunately you're not going
to be the best friend I'm sorry
and you know we're whipping through the
highlights and then this season a lot of
the highlights or awkward like this
iconic group date where the men had to
teach sex education to children girls
don't be freaked out but the lining of
your uterus is gonna shed it kind of
like dies now luckily luckily thank God
these kids were child actors because
don't drink for every and frankly
horrifying explanation that was given
right here is the vagina a condom is
actually something that the boy would
this is gonna be a make-believe okay but
one guy who wasn't bad and I couldn't
believe it
were you surprised by it in the
beginning two people fall in love
yes Ben Higgins was a standout on
Kaitlyn's season and he even stood out
on this group date by standing up and
making himself a human sperm there's one
lucky one me today
yes Ben was a sperm and he told everyone
Caitlin was an ovary there's a nice
circle around Caitlin right here and
then they came at each other at this
point it's the start of real human
beings okay Matt sex education but he
did the best and he even had a big
finish he was innocent okay Gabe Caitlin
a really beautiful kind of cinematic dip
owl night-night
this is as much as I can dip a kiss it
was a cinematic moment but this show
isn't just to look back it's a catch up
so we've got the sperm I mean Ben
Higgins on a zoom absolutely fantastic
those sperm they just zoom around and
don't drink every time then and Chris
dropped some knowledge during this zoom
call some bizarre I was actually a sex
ed minor in college what it's just
bizarre because of all people it's been
I guess that's great if you're gonna go
on a bachelor bachelorette show you know
you're like I am super prepared at the
fantasy suite mmm you're like I
literally studied for this and like I
have a degree to be here but look if you
thought on the bachelor and the
Bachelorette we move from person to
person real quick this is a recap show
so goodbye Ben let's talk about Jared by
the way are you guys liking The Bachelor
greatest seasons ever go to Bachelor
greatest of all time whatever the fish
show is called
The Bachelor the greatest seasons ever
let me know in the comments below
so obviously Jared is now married to
Ashlee I and do you know the bachelor is
a franchise that's full of crossover
isn't it and it's lovely when that
crossover works out because Ashley I and
Kaitlyn be actually both knew each other
from Chris soules season and then Jared
ADA Kaitlyn on her season and then now
Jared is married to Ashley eyes so it's
like a bachelor up family tree Cheers
mmm I love it I love love and the people
found love it's weird to think about
where it all started
what I do like is catching up with
people and it's just like how are you
I'm happy because we know Jared and
Ashley are happy they're married right
now because of the quarantine they are
staying with her parents as for Ashley
you know her husband Jared asked to talk
about dating her friend Kaitlyn right
now
don't drink every time she said I think
there was a time we thought this may be
the guy Wow if we hadn't talked about
sex enough yet
now we're just gonna catch up with
Ashley and Jared on their sex lives
how do those intimate moments go they
said they're having to be and I quote
quietly intimates staying with their
parents during the quarantine quietly
did we need that our parents probably
gonna watch this no judge I don't know
let me know in the comments below
sure I hope we get a Jared and Ashley
baby out of it
just sayin but now on to a different
relationship
an iconic bromance Clint and JJ do you
guys remember these two it was kind of
like a blonde gasps dawn and a bad
Prince Eric they were bros they loved
each other but they were villains don't
drink for every bromantic moment between
these do you own me now and you hold my
wrists on but for the smartest or the
Brainiac see ya trailer turtles are
awesome to the club I loved her but is
bro E and showy and go E as Clint and JJ
were there was a lesson in all this
everybody if you're going to say
villains gotta Vil no one's gotta know
you gotta know that when you gotta go
your bro might show you super dark and
backstabbing colors why say sorry it's
all of us right now I think that means
me
uh yes Kaitlyn Bristowe sent Clint home
JJ threw him under the bus said he
needed to apologize to everyone and then
and then and then this was dark sorry
for Jonah don't touch me I just went in
there and I asked you to back me up even
dude
JJ cried when Clint left and that's
tough enough but then in a moment I do
remember he slapped himself in the face
to stop himself from crying embrace the
fields allow the emotions I always say
feel it well but do not dwell have the
moment and then move on but don't hit
yourself yes I know JJ's now met someone
and I think he's either engaged or
married he's happy so good for him okay
and now we are zooming back over to the
zooms we've had a lot of questionably
iconic to us on this episode Kaitlyn and
Britt JJ and Clint and now Hannah and
Madison we have definitely had some big
moments together yes we are catching up
with Peter Webber's two most recent exes
and you know what did you guys think of
the conversation they had with Chris I
thought it was great
he asked Madison if she still had any
feelings about barb and what your
thought on on barb how you were treated
because on the premiere barb appeared
with Peter and Kelly Flannigan and she
did a cheerleading chant is supporting
their relationship
and we all know what Barb's thoughts on
Peters relationship with Madison where
it's not gonna work but you know Madison
said hey I've experienced growth I don't
hold any grudges there's absolutely no
hard feelings there she is a great mom
and she was just doing her job as a mom
to protect her son and Hannah and
Madison said they're they're great
friends now we're on great work yes
we're good friends
cheers to growth and friendship and
moving forward so at this point
everybody we've talked about some of the
major guys on Kaitlyn's season the
frontrunners the guys who she connected
with but there's something we can't
forget Nick vile I looked over and I was
like this is the second coming of Nick
via and you guys the way that make
entered was iconic he wasn't on the
season from the start Caitlin and the
guys had been filming for a month at
this point they go on a group date and
Nick's like
he shows up with Ashley I and Kaitlyn
did not want to say bye just a little
blown I know no no yes yes yes
don't drink for how excited Kaitlyn
Bristowe was but Nick my I was there so
Kaitlyn and Nick said that after Nick
was on Andi Dorfman season they had been
flirting Nick and I talked a couple
times over text
don't drink for every face the guys make
when they find out that Nick Viall
is here for a while like he's here I
realize that's gonna cause some serious
problems we all put our lives on hold
if Nick V does show up I don't think any
of you guys are gonna take a liking to
him coming in soon nick enters the room
and there's an awkward silence
sup guys what's up yeah
I wish I had more ice I can get more I'm
in my home okay we're not in the studio
I'll be back buddy
just a second luckily I mean a wireless
microphone so you can just whatever say
[Music]
I'm kind of like this inconvenient okay
are you guys liking being at home at
this point is it sunk in have you
adjusted or are you ready to break free
let me know in the comments below
sup guys Nick enters the room with the
guys and there's an awkward silence but
what's worse is that when he starts
going on the group dates he does things
like stick around for a while and I
gotta admit I didn't know Nick's voice
was that bad
I'm gonna have to ask him if he was like
thinking that the thing is you guys we
must remember villains gotta Vil guns
gotta go Nick Viall was kind of a Ville
at this point this guy's full of I mean
at the time everyone thought Nick was
bad don't drink for everyone who said
Nick was bad
that's guys for nothing about him is
good he's just a pompous arrogant guy
everyone now imma set my glass down
because I have to prepare for what is
one of the strangest wildest in weirdest
moments in bachelor franchise history
and I wasn't doing roses in rows a
during Kaitlyn's season so I've never
spoken about it before
and it is the moment I call that door
the door closed Katelyn and Nick were
behind it and what we heard
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not like look hookups do whatever
you want to do it's a thing to have said
I don't know what it means it was a
cinematic choice to close the door and
for us to just hear the full sentence is
okay yeah now look that moment was
wonderfully weird and unforgettable but
it was also at the time very
controversial Kate we've got a lot of
hate for it a lot of judgement
essentially because she was a woman who
had sex before the fantasy suites on the
show and I just want to throw my support
behind Caitlin and we're all here to say
that wasn't fair but enough about Nick
what about Sean you nervous right now
yes Kaitlyn Bristowe had told Sean booth
he was the line but then her and Nick
went behind that door
so she had to tell Sean oh god this is
so awkward it's hard for me to admit it
but we had sex
yeah no I just kind of started seeing
the jaws theme song without even knowing
moment between Kaitlyn and Shawn and
ultimately it's down to Nick and Shawn
in the end and for some reason we went
back to the mansions for the proposals
which I didn't remember did they always
use to do that let me know in the
comments below I look at you and I have
such confidence in you and in us and
beardless Nick going to propose and
don't drink every time he said Kaitlyn
is what my absolute see a future Kayla
it's become increasingly harder and
harder to see it go any other way other
than ending up with Kaitlyn I thought
not pretty lucky fella and then about
let us go you know I am yours forever
if you'll have me Oh God in Kaitlyn's
face oh it's just like when's she going
to stop it and then she does kill him No
and Nick's not happy we can't blame him
and yes this is the highlights
CliffsNotes show but they're gonna play
this whole breakup oh she's crying he's
calling her out you took things for me
that was because it was real to me in
those wasn't that real and he drops on
her this sentence listen if you were in
love with me we would be having a
different conversation I don't think
that's true I don't really think either
of them is wrong here do you let me know
in the comments below
oh but Nick Vilas good TV because before
he left
he threw the ring and not even one ring
but two cuz he had the one he was going
to propose with and one that he like
bought for Caitlyn is like a memento and
Ireland he threw two rings hey Chris I
do I'm buddy
and now back to the sperm zoom call and
again
Nicki's good TV we get a reveal nick
tells everyone the back of the day when
Caitlin was still questionably the
Bachelorette when it was both her and
Britt and they were going to be pitted
against each other on night 1 of the new
season of Bachelor at the before that
they were on the show Jimmy Kimmel Live
because Jimmy Kimmel is on you see it's
an affiliated network with the show of
course and so Jimmy kill always
interviews the new Bachelorette so
Kaitlyn and Britt went on the show and
Nick reveals that Kaitlyn gave him up
Kaitlyn gave you a sign she yeah she's
like I'm about to go on stage
it was weird wasn't it I guess because
Kaitlyn and Nick had been talking on
social media she told him that she would
send him a sign that she was thinking of
him when she went on Jimmy Kimmel and
the sign was this she's like I'm about
to go on stage I'm gonna I'm going to
kiss my finger so we're great how's it
gonna work do you know the guys are
going to touches her lips why not
something more natural like like what is
that I don't know why do people do that
does anyone have a better signal
suggestion let me know in the comments
below and really don't drink for every
reveal from Nick he also tells us that
not only did he and talen use social
media and talked a couple times over
text they also use email to exchange
love letters from him to her yeah
they're even I had told her that I was
going to email her while she was filming
the show and the reveal that I felt was
the wildest Nick admits that when
Kaitlyn broke up with him he wanted to
and I quote push her in the pool in that
moment when she broke up with me I
remember wanting it to push her in the
pool
great choice to not do that but much
more importantly now Caitlyn is here
with her blonde hair it's fun to relive
it and I'm looking at all the positives
now we didn't see Shawn's proposal to
Caitlyn honestly probably because let's
save Caitlyn from that and with another
Bachelor crossover moment Caitlyn's now
dating Jason and overall what did you
think of Kaitlyn's season episode let me
know in the comments below but before we
go whoa whoa whoa we gotta ask a big
question
you know I'm an ordained minister oh are
you is Jason gonna propose
oh you know what Caitlyn thought was a
ring box in Jason's pocket was his err
paused I only laugh about this guys
because I've talked to Jason and Caitlyn
about it they love each other they plan
to get married a bit of a fake-out in
all seriousness I do have a very very
real question for you Caitlyn okay but
there was a question to be asked and
honestly I was so happy to see this
everybody Kaitlyn Bristowe grew up being
a dancer she had long wanted to go on
Dancing with the Stars and she had
accused in the past Bachelor creator
Mike Fleiss of stopping her from doing
so well guess what finally Kaitlyn
Bristowe is going on Dancing with the
Stars Kaitlyn will you be on the next
season of Dancing with the Stars
what did you guys think of this moment I
truly teared up a little bit and got
goose bumps
kaitlin's worked super hard so happy for
her who she is going to a coup reshet
yes cuz I need a yes or no
[Music]
oh I can't do any dance moves really
like ah okay everybody that is it for
this episode of The Bachelor greatest
seasons of all time greatest seasons
ever the goat whatever the bachelor the
greatest seasons ever
we will be back next week for more roses
and Rosie I love you guys so much thank
you for watching know that I am sending
you my love and appreciation and we are
gonna be here every week to have a
little fun together and have a smile and
I adore you all okay you guys are the
greatest of all time
hey oh you wanted to come here too
look I get it we're like JJ and Clint
you know you can't have one without the
other
I won't backstab you though here you go
okay Cheers
I can't have any of this you're not old
enough okay love you see you tonight at
my dreams slash nightmares bye
[Music]
you